knowing that it was Tom and Ariana and
you've spent time with both of them as a
couple were you surprised that he
cheated on her yes no because I I was
there for the first week during the
Miami situation right I was there the
week they started dating when this
happened I said it many times Jax Taylor
has entered the scandival chat I mean I
don't want to say I predicted it but I
predicted it on Wednesday the Vanderpump
Rules Alum stopped by Watch What Happens
live with his wife Brittany Cartwright
and made an explosive Claim about Tom
Sandoval has Sandoval cheated on Ariana
before yes 100 100 percent
I told you I was there not only in the
Miami situation that was week one of the
relationship by the way but yeah there's
been other times
a lot of times I just it doesn't matter
if you've done it one or ten times you
did it in the last couple years would
you yeah what would you know I just know
I just know things fans will recall in
season three Sandoval was accused of
cheating on his girlfriend Ariana Maddox
with a woman in Miami we had sex no we
didn't yes
of course this all comes after news
broke that Sandoval cheated on his
girlfriend of nine years with their
co-star and friend Raquel Levis I'm just
not surprised I'm just not surprised
I'll just leave it that I don't really
know I think it's surprising that it was
them too for sure he's been with Ariana
frog yes almost 10 years and you know
best friends with Raquel this isn't just
a I hooked up with somebody there's lack
of empathy there there it was like a
premeditated
situation Jax and Brittany haven't been
on the show for the past two seasons but
say they're still good friends with most
of the cast and have been in touch with
most of them since scandaval first
erupted including Ariana I've checked in
on Ariana a couple times I know that she
hasn't been alone for a second so that
was good I think she's just super
shocked now one of the big questions
fans want answers to is how long the
other Tom Tom Schwartz knew about the
affair I talk to sports every day so I
know for a fact for 100 fact on my child
he told me he knew how long though you
don't know how long no he told he said
he goes I know I've knew for a while he
kind of left it at that but then he said
I tried to tell him to come forward with
it Jax and Brittany also
Hardy they were
they were Ariana called him and said hey
my grandmother was passed away or got
sick or something and he didn't go home
he didn't leave he used the fact that he
couldn't get an Uber
and meanwhile people were coming in and
out of the house all day long because it
was a it was a party and Jax who's faced
his own cheating scandals in the past
offers a little advice to Sandoval you
know we all make mistakes in life you
know we God knows I've made my fair
share I would just you know just try to
be a little humble humble like yeah he's
got to like come down to earth and
realize what he's done just humble
yourself a little bit
[Music]
thank you